welcome back it hasn't been the best of
weeks for late night American talk show
hosts but Trevor Noah very much
delivered a hold my beer moment to James
Corden last night just take a look at
this
watching the story of Rishi sunak
becoming England's first prime minister
of color of Indian descent of all of
these things and then seeing the
backlash is one of the more telling
um it's just one of the more telling
things about how people view the role
that they or their people have played in
in history and what I mean by that is
this you hear a lot of the people saying
oh you they're taking over there you you
know now the Indians are going to take
over Great Britain and and what's next
and what and I and I I always find
myself going
so what
what
what's the backlash exactly who's seen
the backlash there seems to be an
entirely imaginary thing it's like this
is just happening in Trevor Noah's head
I don't know if I missed something my I
think not now joining us from Alabama to
discuss Noah's bizarre rant is American
political commentator CJ Pearson
thanks for having me it's great to have
you with us what did you make of this uh
CJ I mean it it just strikes me as
something from a different planet
yeah but it's also a broken record
unfortunately we have to deal with that
here in America every single day of
people like Trevor Noah looking to blame
racism on every single thing in the
world you know they call our country
fundamentally racist and I guess now you
guys are getting the same treatment but
notice in that segment he didn't point
out the people that are actually
attacking the new prime minister because
they're not from the conservative party
so I wonder who those people must be no
but apparently it this all came from one
caller calling into a popular radio show
here I mean that there has been Rishi
sunak's coronation as our as our prime
minister has been welcomed by everybody
including by by President Biden who who
called him Rashad Sanuk or something uh
but yeah anyway apart from that everyone
seems to have welcomed it warmly
to paint the UK as having a problem with
us having
um a prime minister of of well with with
Indian parents
because he doesn't possess the death to
talk about real issues he's in Possessed
enough to talk about global inflation it
doesn't possess the death to talk about
UK politics or anything like that but
what he can do is make everyone out to
be some racist Boogeyman this is exactly
what the left does every single day
where there isn't a issue or with race
at all they make it to be as if it's
something that you should consume
yourself with every single day people
are championing uh the new prime
minister of UK and for good reason it's
a huge milestone but let's also point
out the historical fact that every
single modern PM that we've had that's
been a female has been from the
conservative party and now the first
Indian English uh man who is a British
PM from the conservative party where's
labor at on that I don't see him at all
well one of the other interesting things
about this CJ is the fact that all this
has this weird American lens put over it
I mean you know every country has its
own historical problems every country
has its own issues but this is like
watching a well first of all Trevor
knows who grew up in South Africa so
maybe he sort of sees some of this
through the lens of apartheid but he
then transport transfers that onto
America and there from that transfers
that onto the UK and it seems to be just
it just doesn't work in the most
remarkable thing about about uh about
our prime minister is the fact that race
and religion weren't an issue at any
stage in the campaign for anyone there
nobody said he he should get the job
because of his race or his his religion
they said he should get the job because
they thought he was the best person for
the job
yeah you know and what's what's most
exhausting about the narrative you're
hearing from Trevor and this is plagued
America for far too long is this
Perpetual need to be a victim and to see
victimhood in every single story this is
a moment of Triumph This is a moment of
something that you would think Trevor
Noah would be heralding but instead he's
trying to point out racism simply where
it isn't and you have to wonder why is
there that incessant need for them to
have racism in a society why is there
this incessant need for them to have
someone be a victim it just goes to show
that the only thing they know how to do
is divide and conquer they seek to do
that through race religion and so much
more and yet they blame conservatives
for doing just that but they do it every
single day but I think is it not true to
say there are still there are still
problems with race and we we have still
some issues here in Britain and you
still definitely have some issues in
America and these problems exist around
the world but it seems a like a sort of
cry wolf situation here where why wasn't
he why wasn't he celebrating how how
enthusiastic we were with our new prime
minister wouldn't get him the ratings
that's why well I I think it's just made
him look rather stupid and ill-informed
myself
as a person of color
completely agree with you but the thing
about race here is if you call
everything racist no one's going to
believe you when something actually is
racist and that's the thing that these
people don't
understanding real issues
exactly that exactly this is a moment to
be celebrated uh and not shamed and it's
unfortunate that Trevor decided to Reign
on what otherwise is a very historic
moment in the UK right now and what
about in America CJ how's this gone down
is is Trevor Noah's ratings and the late
night shows gonna go up or down on the
basis of this
well notice Trevor Noah is leaving the
Late Night show so I guess that says
everything uh that needs to be said
about his incredible career here he can
go out on a sour note
thanks CJ exactly that thanks so much
thank you